jusqu'à douze nominations de trois
petits jeux gratuits c'est parti le
premier best in show on incarne une
vache qui peut s'étirer vous voyez
chaque boutique contrôler le boudent le
cul et la tête et en fait on vient de
gagner un concours de vaches le truc
c'est que nous on n'est pas une vache on
est deux mecs déguisés en match oui si
on s'est élargie trop voyez ça va voilà
c'est parti à s'échapper
on va s'échapper va faire la vache la
plus naturelle du monde en plus j
approche de plus afin de valoriser hôtel
donc je sais comment il se comporte
on est bien là mais encaissent des trucs
nord mais ils vont paniquer on a une
valse bourrée on revient deux soirs ils
ont des vaches bourré comme les humains
il ya rien de rien je suis vachement je
suis une femme normale
ok je me pète jeune belge en fait ils
sont pleins non mais je suis une vache
tranquille a été de faire genre j'ai vu
plusieurs vaches venir avant dans cet
hôtel arrêté mais c'est pas du tout à la
fois l'ex juge cette fois elle au bout
du rouleau mais ils sont un millier en
bec a pas bon ménage et bloquer le
passage s'il vous plaît quelqu'un du
staff pour m'aider en mairie malgré non
mais non mais non
bel la vache elle se sent libéré des
livres et consorts de son corps nous
sommes juste tout ce qu'il a de plus
normal une vache de te mettre dans un
hôtel me dites pas que vous n'avez
jamais vu ça ce j'aimais ça votre vie
des sujets croire la porte du smoking
mais c'est un sketch on est bien on va
dans cette chambre
mais pour ckoi le manger plus de boeuf
de ma vie voilà vous êtes fautes en 7
potage mois république koffi j'ai mangé
dans du sable je suis un guerrier
puissance comme ça qu'on se forge mais
non mes mecs c'est le poids en eau du
concours qui les paye quoi ces moments
je m'en bats les couilles c'est bon tu
es sous le pas ces pages est bouffé plus
en plus d'ouvrir cette vache qui paye
tout album commence enfin à marmara
justin lavash à y en a un il y en a un
mais par toi mieux pas se barrer lui en
guise vert il vient y vient faut que je
passe devant lui rapidement chez une
vache normal non non mais non mais non
mais le mec qui m'insultent cetto -
chien bo gars on va amener ces deux
vaches vers la liberté vers la sortie
elle pour aller loin mais si le coût de
cette niche n'accrochait pas à tout ce
qui bouge y compris au mieux en [ __ ]
ça sortirait de quoi sont que tu as
besoin de frotter des choses tout le
temps c'est infernal en ont on se cache
steak haché pur boeuf pour la vache la
blague au bon il m'a pas vu ivan force
ça mais faut traire c'est tout lu tout
l'immeuble quoi à y aller faut y aller
faut y aller on se cache au oui oh oui
quelle opportunité alors l'annoncé qu'il
faut tenir compte des deux potes chez
entre les deux petits sont pleins ils
sont pleins les baisers en dvd d'un
c'est bon c'est bon alors une
opportunité comme salah de couler dans
le pré de manger de l'herbe sa saisie
qu'une seule fois dans le match c'est
tout droit c'est parti on a passé tous
les gars mais assorti la sortie regardez
regardez regardez on voit le poids des
matches là j'arrive je suis là non on a
brisé une si belle histoire d'amour je
culpabilise ces deux mammifères ne se
retrouveront jamais pour s'accoupler
peut-être donné naissance est un petit
bourg s'est elle est moche et pas les
autres jeux
maintenant si on a trahi leur turbo
c'est ça ou c'est fort de la xviii voilà
alors par un bond dans le futur c'est
parti regardez ces graphies ce réalisme
à on peut prendre le volant vraiment
pour conduire doucement et et frôlé
l'accident ces manifs on s'en sort mais
je vois plus rien à défaut je peux les
pare brise ça marche pas pu un match
y'a pas mais mon côté je me crois qu'il
apporte quoi ces armes et où c'est un
conteur j'appuie sur des boutons
salvetat mais s'il est poussé une [ __ ]
de fusées mec ce tableau d'honneur sont
plus rien c'est la passe là bas on est
mort électrocuté mille fois en plus on a
quand même fait 1748 kilomètres pour
aller au zoo de beauval tu fais moins
que ça mon gars et la route elle est
bien plus sûre on est les nouveaux
sébastien loeb
entré aux initiales spn je sais pourquoi
alors je crois qu'il faut juste bouger
le volant tout doux ne faut pas
s'affoler
on ne sait pas grave on lui rentrer
dedans à daya bon c'est pas grave on lui
rentré d c'est grave on n'a plus de
volant mais bender eye-fi pare brise
on va faire mieux on va faire durer ces
achats n'ont pas de repères je voulais
match m'a rappelé et esthétique ou du
bien on sait pas quand mon chouchou
on a de l'huile sur fabrice hebrard il
paraît que ça fait mieux aux crises et
l'air qu'on va beaucoup plus vite c'est
faux dans le contrôle de sa csmb merde
c'est quoi j'arrache tout j'arrache
touche plus que moi bastareaud il m'a
tout appris à 1793 kilomètres là on
était curieux et équipe mais tv2 au
volant quelques temps plus tard on peut
faire mieux on va passer la barre des
2000 déjà commencé par les à la salle a
musclé son petit bras à bout de bras sur
la file de droite suffit de cocher la
mer il ya des clans pas des mamies qui
passent le permis c'est pas grave
l'ipcc ou 3 et sébastien fait comme cela
est alors l on est bien on est bien on
est bien on est bien on a battu le
record du chic on a battu records en
verre regardez bien regardez bien vous
ai pas regardé j'espère à si je peux
freiner je peux freiner monfreid de
safer peu de rythme il ya plus de freins
ni calquella on est bien là on est bien
on est bien là ya du talent là y ait un
réel talent - oh là là mais jamais fait
un début aussi bien dans le volant à
chaque fois et se voulant repousser le
plus tard mettez vous mettez un truc
aller embrasser 2000 mec je vous le dis
on passe les 2000 c'est parti on est
chaud on n'est jamais aussi mois au fait
les 2000 tant que telle remontée bien ah
merde
ah ouais non là on est malin et dans le
marais normal on n'a plus qu'une genre
tu n'as plus qu'une vie tarik suis sûr
qu'on avait plus de mise je suis sûr je
parie ma chaîne youtube
lefort l'effort
c'est pas le petit matin l'entourage
fait le fils de sébastien loeb allait
tout trophée tu as gagné une plante
connard jeu super héros [ __ ] merci
merci ça me touche beaucoup mais c'est à
lui maintenant cambriolé john travolta
oui oui oui nous sommes sûrs qu'on
refuse travolta keker extrême et en gros
il faut juste volé quand ils me
regardent le pas voyez donc la fda comme
roller 3000 quoi on est bien on est bien
on est cadre à deux volets tous ont hâte
sont vos canapés sont ouverts ce tableau
ou aparté avec les murs carrément autant
le volet lui quoi ça va plus vite il ya
plus de valeur en plus les kiwis les
fourreaux en abyme il n'y a plus rien et
voilà c'est fait john travolta si tu as
besoin d'aménager ailleurs appel nous
fera pas le temps de nous voir qu'on
aura déjà tout déménagé level 2 adacore
faut faire plaisir aux filles tant
qu'ils ne regardent pas ce qui les
protège de saad
attention puisqu'il est à l'affût quand
même il veut pas trop qu'on touche chez
fido regardez le avec ce moyen de
pervers ça s'est super bien avec chico
jusqu'à combien bordel de merde c'est
trop stressant doit pas recevoir
maintenant l'audi est trop forte dans
l'utah mais non mais non plus pas plus
je te jal s'est fait plaisir tout seul
et c'est toucher le tt là en me confiant
d'ailleurs elle a pris la même façon de
faire que moi elle son plaisir dans son
dos et elle montera à les sahraouis il
faut défendre le vaisseau mère
d'ailleurs à la perrière pas inquiet
plus je tire puisse retourner arrête de
regarder mes mecs c'est n'importe quoi
c'est bon là on n'a pas ces mecs arrêtez
arrêtez c'est quoi ton petit peu malade
il devrait y toutes leurs armes et mais
qd on a gagné au québec a souffert quoi
et les blocs qui tombe voulait faire
tomber sans qu'ils aient le temps de les
voir ok ok ok c'est pas mal ça au stylet
bitola la cellule affolé on est bien là
on est bien on est bien c'est gagner
avec son appartement
sa femme bien aimée et sa voiture
détruit travolta a tout perdu et donc
ouais non qui je dois faire ah c'est moi
qu'ils jouent ok d'accord
travolta pas content brouillard on
l'appelle travaux lilas et voilà raven
tazi la [ __ ] je le mets la même idée
que moi
game over vous avez gagné je comprends
pas trop alors je gagnais où j'ai perdu
mon la magie du montage
vous avez gagné vous êtes un youtuber
ornans dites à vos abonnés de s'abonner
parce que ça vaut le coup abonnez vous
oui bonne chance qui est ainsi donnée ce
n'est pas d'aimer ça vous a plu les
liens sont les questions si vous les
jouets jeux sont gratuits n'hésitez pas
même la vidéo pensez vous bien sûr le
monde crise